جود عزيز 25 سؤال لازم جواب عليهم بسرعه
من غير تفكير كيف انشرتي
فتحت حساب في الانستغرام وما كنت متوقع
هذا الشيء اساسا والناس كمان تتابعني ممكن
بس يعني في شيء معين الاعتراف
انتشرت من عندها قبل فلما فتحت حساب الناس
قاعده تدور الحساب في ناس بتقول انه جود
عزيز لا تجيد التمثيل ابدا ودخلت التمثيل
من باب انها مشهوره على مواقع التواصل كيف
تردي ااا نهائيا الموضوع مو كده يعني قبل
ما ندخل اي مسلسل لازم يكون في تدريبات
لازم يكون فيه كاستنج عشان نتاكد من هذه
الاشياء
يعني مو الموضوع مو حي الله جيتك يعني
اوكي طيب ارتبطتي بالممثل باسم طلال رحتوا
مع بعض
التواصل وحكيته عن قصه حبكم
ااا اول شايف البدايه كنت ابغى هذا
الموضوع اصلا يبقى خصوصيه بيننا لكن الناس
اكتشفت كل شيء فخلاص طلع للناس وبما انه
خلاص تم الانفصال همم فالحمد لله على كل
حال والله يوفق الجميع يارب العالمين
اتمنى لك الخير بس انتم تركتوا ورجعتم
وتركتم ورجعتموا قدام الناس
انا مالي دخل قصدك انه هو اللي كتب
البوستات يعني
يعني اوكي طب ليش تركته
الله يوفق الجميع خلاص اوكي
الحمدلور قدمتيه اهم دور قدمتها
امم
شخصيه فخريه في مسلسل الجنيه اللي انعرض
على شاهد اوكي لبست الحجاب وقلتي هتبعدي
وبعدين خلعتيه والناس اتهامتك انك عملتي
هذه كله عشان المشاهدات اول شيء ابدا
اوكي بس النمو على المشاهدات
اكيد يعني بس انه قصدي
بحث عن الاذان
يعني ان شاء الله امورك
اقدر اقول بس
انا ما عندي احد معين حتى ولا احد عالمي
ممكن تقولي اسم عالمي اذا بتحرج انه مثلا
احد عربي خليجي
صعب جدا
نقله دبي هنا بدون اهلي
ما كان في شيء اقصى من كده الحمد لله
باسم قبل ما تتركوه فيديو قديم بتتكلمي
فيه او بتكلمي في نفسك في المراه
حوار مع النفس الناس صراحه سخروا منك كثير
على هذا الموضوع وهذه الفكره
الفيديو حبيبي
[موسيقى]
20 اوكي بس مثلا يعني الواحد يكون مثلا
عمل فني هالو اعلان هو يعني ايش يكون كيفك
كيف شيء يكون عالمي يوصلك العالميه
الطرفين ممكن كده
بس انك انت رايحه للعالمين اوكي هل بتزوري
طبيب نفسي
ههه
[ضحك]
اه انفلونسر بلوجر ما ادري يعني همم
مجموعه انسان يمكن مجموعه انسان اوكي طيب
كيف بتردي على اللي يقول لك محتوى كافه
اخر كتاب قراتيه
اه ايش كان اسمه يا ربي
فقدان الذاكره اوكي
انت كذا طيحتيني بالفخ على فكره ليه
نجمات من اي ناحيه
نجمه الفنان الاولى في السعوديه
اثنين اثنين بس
انا صراحه يعني ما اغار من المواضيع
العاديه
في المستقبل
طيب كان ممكن اليوم تكوني مليونيره بس انت
صريفه جدا لقيت درجه هذا الكلام صحيح مين
قال
يعني
بيوجعك يا جود على طول
طيب تخافي من العين يعني طيب صحباتك قولي
له بيتغيروا قله ثقه منك في الناس او تقلب
شخصيتك او المشكله منه
وبعدين او انا اكتشف شخصياتهم متاخر
بتحسي انه المشكله في الناس اتمنى يعني
ههه لان ده صارت المشكله مني ما ادري شو
راح اسوي ههه
اعجبتني هذه الاشاره اوكي طيب يا ريت هم
اللي يطلعوا المشكله طيب اغنيه عبر عن
حياتك او حالتك النفسيه اه
حاليا ولا بشكل عام حاليا مثلا بشكل عمتي
الاثنين اللي يعجبك بشكل عام في اغنيه
اليسا بس نسيت اسم الاغنيه بالضبط بكره
همم انا من جوايا عكس اللي شايفينها ما
اعرف اسم الاغنيه بس هذه ههه
هذه الاغنيه
بشكل
عام هذه بشكل عام حاليا
ها
العجل
ان شاء الله اكيد كلنا عندنا عجول في ناس
ما تستخدم عقلهم بالطريقه الصحيحه فانا
اتمنى ان عاقل عاقل
شكرا لك
[ضحك]